hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to west of loathing
putting on the Hat was a mistake a bad
grievous mistake and error and here's
why okay that is a lot harder oh no oh
no ahhh
yo desperately heal oh my god if every
fight is like this from now on I'm so
bone now that I've presented the
evidence of why you should not do that I
have not started a completely new game
my name is still mum floor pumper dink I
have still done everything that I have
done so far up until now except I had a
bunch more cactuses and I got the perk
mostly scabs which is nice because it
gives me more health but that's the only
difference now the other thing that I
have done differently is I have not
killed the goblin yet I have learned the
goblin primer and I am ready to see what
this goblin has to say to me if indeed I
can talk to this I got a sneak up on
this goblin the goblin shouts I'm Gary
hi Gary
hi hello hello I am Gary who are you
introduce yourself I'm mum Fleur hello
hello I'm Fleur good to meet you what
mum Fleur doing down here well be polite
I guess I don't want to say that I was
here to kill you that would be weird huh
be polite
oh-ho Gary likes to looking - Gary now
looking for a way out of this dump
Gary not having much luck though where
are you trying to go Gary highway
highway and far up for popping popping
in the new Gary everywhere everywhere
everywhere
settle down Gary Gary doesn't like to
settling Gary wants to travelling and
popping if mum Fleur going far up and
high away maybe taking Gary with you eh
eh I'll think about it oh boy oh boy boy
boy I could take Gary with me that's my
companionless oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy
do that anyway so I think we're done in
this town and I think we're everywhere
that we need to be can you sell me a
horse sure thing I should warn you
though horses get mighty attached to
their riders once you've bought one you
won't be able to change your mind later
what's he interested in the basic model
the shifty looking dark one the spooky
one give you the one with the crazy eyes
I'll take the crazy one
ah okay I gotta warn you this waters has
seen some some stuff but I'll sell them
to you for a thousand meet is something
wrong with him no not as such he's
perfectly functional more altar boy well
he always sneaking off to a thousand
snakes Gulch to chew on the local weed
that grows there and that makes him see
crazy things I think it's more like he
does it to forget about the crazy things
he sees all the time anyway color me
intrigued I'll take him here's the keys
ride save give him a name Oh Tim oh he's
already named Tim oh hell yeah I'm gonna
name him Tim I'm gonna name him Tim
Fleur welcome Tim Fleur to the fun /
ding family you're a part of this now
with a hue like it or not are you sure
you wanna name your horse Templar I've
never been sure more sure of anything in
my life so let's go to it it's got a
nice ring to it
oh and I almost forgot free with every
horse purchase is a complimentary map
okay thank you
ride Templar out of town any unfinished
business you will you've got will
forever remain unfinished sure you ready
uh ah I mean what else is there to do
right I think I did everything so I
think I'm good all righty then you're
probably horst and ready to start your
new life west all you need now is a
partner somebody to share the trail with
somebody you can rely on for emotional
and combat support who you take crazy
Pete doc Alice Susie Cochran Gary Goblin
go it alone on second thought
I like me some Gary I don't know what
he's talking about about popping
everywhere making new Gary's have a
funny feeling that's reproducing but
okay crazy Pete would be interesting but
I think I'd get tired of the accent doc
alice is just burying herself and drink
Susie Cochran has a vengeance plan
that'd be like the typical choice that I
would do Susie Cochran seems like a good
reason to take him out west because she
she's got no family here and she's got a
thirst for vengeance which I can always
use but I think Gary the guy it's gonna
be just interesting you head back to the
saloons basement and smuggle care under
your coat hit the trail uh-oh
up until this point I've been
automatically spending I spent it
manually
okay all right option turning yourself
into some kind of unbalanced weirdo if
you want check your map all right head
for dirt water okay all right so now
that we got that all out of the way and
we've gotten over here I could it was I
got up to this point last time I played
through with the hat on and it was a
goddamn mistake because the first battle
that I went into on the road to the next
area was um
yeah it didn't go so good for me so
don't do that
Oh Tim Fleur whinnies comb his mane he
makes sort of a glurk noise all right
I'll leave them alone hey buddy it's
your partner Zee howdy Gary wanting more
cob lens meeting Gary is hearing about
goblins hold for nearby hmm okay all
right anything what do you think we
should do next
West is going fast okay a big iron snake
to riding so fast taking us a big iron
you mean the Train yes
asking the trains man's okey dokey all
righty then any other ideas you got Gary
uh what do you think we should do next
no any other ideas Gary says you should
see the bartender about renting a room
alright ok alright see you Gary hey
buddy how's it going whoo
howdy there oh it's nice to see a new
face in town welcome to the jewel saloon
hi thanks a muffler glad to know your
mom Fleur folks around here just call me
Lloyd whoo what can I do for you now
it's me Lloyd
I saw you advertising a room that's
right finest room in the house and
plenty of room for apartment 2 you
interested how much is it cost well
that's where you're in luck the previous
tenant was a banker fella and be paid a
month in advance right before getting
himself killed by bandits you seem like
a decent sort so your rooms if you want
it okay all right I'm an act surprised
because I already knew about that oh
he's so nice what do you think of the
jewel saloon Gary nice place many people
gary betting the basement is much nicer
than in boring springs yeah they
probably don't want people going in
their basement oh sorry sorry about that
sorry these guys must have fallen asleep
during a brawl all right this is my
favorite Hey look at yourself in the
mirror and so yourself you call yourself
a possum sniffing green headed jerk
affect is angry which is great because
she kept a lot of muscle moxie and
mystic ality sell yourself again call
yourself a green booted Lily booting
jerk green and Lily I think you got like
plus six across the board which is
pretty nice you bear down and sell
yourself anymore you get any angrier
you're liable to pass out but even with
all of these buffs I couldn't do
anything like anything at all to be able
to withstand the beating I took from the
enemies out there all right what are we
getting here hello there all right ah
bag of shrink ro
advanced cow-punching how many do I have
I have 800 all right I'll get the
binoculars I don't know why I need that
but I'm Gary we'll want this guaranteed
to increase the size and intensity of
any mycological specimen alright well I
don't have a lot of money
and I don't have anything that I want to
sell just yet so I'll go for the Gary
one like why not increase the size of my
Gary hey Gary
I got something for you apparently Gary
give it to Gary you give the bag of
shrooms row to Gary and he tears it up
and starts shoving brown lumps into his
mouth deliciousness jerry has become
more powerful Ruby hey good for Gary
great Gary
hello how's it going both stop it's
boxes one of those newfangled Telegraph
machines
hi I'm mom flirt von bird Inc any mail
three nope
darn well I'd like to send a postcard
all right let's have it you've read a
quick note to Rufus letting them know
that what you've been up to and that
you're okay that'll be oh it's one of
them prepaid ones that'll be zero meat
oh goody goody gumdrops hello little
girls selling flowers if I said oh I got
some sweet smelling flowers oh oh that's
these flowers smell really good I bet
they do I bet they do in DeeDee Doo Dah
all right the clerk clears his throat
howdy are you the sheriff here no we
don't have a sheriff I'll be your
Sheriff do you have law enforcement
experience not really if you been to
Sheriff school no do you have an
existing relationship with dirt waters
local government are you familiar with
the local ordinances do you even live
here new then what may I ask in
tarnation makes you think you'd be
qualified to be a sheriff I just assumed
you just assumed that you can mosey into
town and become sheriff on your first
day well when you put it that way
I had five meet for every wide-eyed
protagonist looking kid who wanders in
here thinking they're the most important
Tenderfoot they have a strap-on iron I
wouldn't need this dead-end clerking job
sorry it's okay
like I said happens all the time need
any help until you find anyone
sure if you're any good with a gun
there's always somebody needed justice
wanted posters back there cells are over
yonder he points behind her and off to
the right respectively okey-dokey then
hello it's a waste wasted the stripy hat
gang for grand theft paint and taste
let's at vandalism last seen in the
vicinity of cavern Canyon dirty rotten
paint thieves okay I'll go after them
alright wanted the house in the desert
gang for mortgage non-payment squatting
and general public nuisance also for
murdering two collection agents last
seen at a desert in the dead house in
the desert is he you wonder if the house
is named after them or if they're named
after the house okay alright got it
alrighty then where am I going now don't
run over me lot available lot available
why are you so angry lady why are you so
angry a lot available a lot available
not a lot of able passes point alrighty
then this is where things went wrong for
me before so on the way yeah you notice
a smoldering hole in the ground have
recognized it as the habitat of the
southeast Western coal snake they keep
to themselves mostly but they're also
known to enjoy fight when once thrust
upon one let's thrust one upon it rust
let's thrust a fight Gary no oh you
caught a whiff of ol Gary did you well
I'm gonna beef up a little bit mmm
that's nice and beefy alright let's see
what we can do but y'all oh it's so much
better Gary what can you do Gary will
Gary foo the target two times dealing 11
of 14 damage with each blow gary will
spawn a goblin grunt - assistant
[Laughter]
I'm just gonna shoot it bang it oh
that's so much better
oh oh you can do with the hard hat the
hard hat so hard
Oh coal snakeskin has been liberated
from a cold snake's body put it on your
hat to add +3 moxie well that sounds
really nice
snake venom bladder and I want that I
don't want that at all
as you dismount and approach the house
where the bandits are holed up you hear
a voice in from inside say what was that
oh let's say you're gonna have to be
sneaky if you want to avoid a full-on
fracas sneak is my middle name
yes it's mum fuller sneaky thumper dink
Oh indeed you do it is alright
you think about this Oh be careful quiet
house angry dog
Gary hoping you are sneaky hmm okay Gary
I'm gonna be sneaking here Oh Tim Fleur
calm down with your craziness for just
one second oh this doghouse contains an
angry dog very funny you're not gonna be
able to get past it without alerting the
gang inside back off for now okay so
there's got to be something I had to see
Oh you find a crate lying by the side of
the trail it slid knocked loose it has
fell off the back of a cart Ltd
stenciled on the side which zips it a
bit on the nose hey free stuff is free
stuff alright I got ranch dressing bar
of soap and a handful of nails good for
me I don't know what those are gonna do
for me but I guess good for me
oh let's see hello Oh
poker tables full up play poker
now rum I'll play poker alright so the
lady do-right introduces herself as
pearl and the player to your left says
his name is gene ante up
you ante up pearl and gene wait why
don't I have gumption and glamour oh
it's a really great hand three tens and
four kings of spades I'm pretty good I
guess check
call pot is 120 meat and you estimate
your chances of winning it around 50%
grit my teeth and raise I got grit baby
flop time to do or die I'm gonna
cleverly raise BAM reveal my cards how
do you have a royal strayed what oh I
win I have a backwards royal full oh
it's completely [ __ ] oh I see oh I
got it oh I get you that makes it work
so rules fours are wild and sixes of
Hearts are double wild one-handed Queens
of spades are double wild jacks are wild
and less company buy two fives
two twos of diamonds and to 180 jacks of
Hearts count as an arizona straight
cross-eyed queen must be replaced with
three queens sixes or what oh my god
that's too many rules for me
alright I'm out of here it doesn't make
any sense hey what do we get spirit
discussion I'll buy some slop okay I got
a plate of slop that's nice
see bartender four darts they're allowed
to drink without hats a stage
are you gonna happen here is there a
point is there a god xp for cleaning it
up a janitor's must be the highest level
sons of [ __ ] around here hello hi
hello hey what are you doing here
employees only bud oh sorry I was just
you know looking around
so you're the nosy type eh I prefer
adventuresome as it happens there's
something you can do for me I'm out of
saltpeter need someone to go pick up me
um some more some saltpeter isn't that
used to make gunpowder and other things
look who's the chef here mayor you okay
okay where can I find it your best bet
some military camp because it's used to
make gunpowder shut up the nearest one
is Fort cowardice they keep it in little
green jars okay all right I'll be right
back
okay all right see you then let's go on
buddy
how's he going man stares off in the
distance he doesn't react at all
all right oh no this is Pitou which is
sort of brass bucket that people's bit
into instead of spitting on the floor
because not spitting it all as an option
in this society I guess I say this
despite knowing that you're pretty
intimately familiar with spittoons
already sick Oh inspected look the jewel
saloon is pretty nice too saloons go
actual glass in the windows more than
two kinds of drinks a poker room instead
of a cockfighting pit but this spittoon
is still a spittoon the rancid tobacco
spit inside it isn't fancy Ranson
tobacco spit inspect it uh here we go
again
all right fine you are now hunkered down
next to a brass filth bucket which has
probably never been cleaned or emptied
because you're near the desert and the
ambient humidity around here is pretty
low low enough that the spit evaporates
nearly as quickly as it accumulates so
that's good right no that's bad because
it's only the water part of the spit the
rates this brass bucket is half-full of
the rest of the spin the toxins and fill
that don't evaporate several years worth
distilled and concentrated until it's
the consistency of molasses people
aren't like cigarette butts into the
spittoon anymore because they bounced
out search it your
about to put your hand into a bucket of
something the color and viscosity of
maple syrup except instead of maple it's
flavored with the inside of the mouths
of people who choose cigars instead of
smoking them much they're deep yeah
dolor it feels like putting your hand
into a bucket of lukewarm tapioca
pudding except instead of tapioca
it's basically poison it smells like
someone ran over a skunk waited a week
and then set it on fire who feels like
your hand is dissolving keep searching
you found something you found a tacky
Filth covered porcelain cow figurine a
useless disgusting thing that will make
a great heirloom for your children
assuming you're still able to have any
edge I got what is that oh you have to
hold this little porcelain cow upside
down because it's filled with tobacco
spit and you don't want to hey bow three
melee attack damage oh man well I have
to get rid of my flowers my nice
smelling flowers for this probably not
nice smelling filthy Kippur Celyn cow
and right there my prize away I need to
apply this to my hat
you put the cold snakeskin on your hat
making it slightly blacker than it was
before at least in the area right above
the brim place is not the hard hat hey I
got an extra to my hat which is nice I
suppose I think so
oh I gotta spend my ex moxie mystic
ality man my buffs have got me way up oh
I guess I could also get more Skills Oh
hold on to that I'll hold on to it just
for a little bit I'll hold on to it
because maybe you never know what I'm
gonna need that later okay but I found
another way didn't know I thought I
found it oh whoa whoa that's big wonder
you've discovered a new map location
silversmiths out okay go there now hello
how's it going a bench and human tools
for looking at this gear looks like for
making bullets Oh
bullets are things - making weird well
somebody has to make them where did you
think they came from thinking they are
gone eggs alrighty then silver bullet
making apparatus help yourself
okay I'm helping myself alright the
workbench has a little burner and
crucible for melting silver things and
making some bullet moles seems pretty
straightforward there's a vise you could
smash silver bullets into needles if you
wanted to make three bullets not
planning on going a weddings or funerals
anytime soon so you figure it's safe to
turn these cufflinks into something
immediately useful okay alright well
silver bullets in case I see like a like
a it's a button calf cactus why don't I
have harvesting why don't I have
harvesting and or dickering all right
door's locked
pick the lock go inside hello Gary
how'd you get in here hello nobody home
nope from all the dust it looks like
they've been gone a while nice so thanks
for being us see whatever isn't nailed
down I guess and what's in here oh god
it's another spittoon oh oh I don't have
any saved crack in it oh no oh God see
find a couple of things that still look
edible all right got that contains 90
copies of Johnny Tremain there's
something weird about it though it's too
neatly organized maybe the guy was
hiding something here
I got enough Moxie because I'm so damn
angry talk behind one of the books you
find a small elephant envelope with
filled with Silver's and receipts about
half of them for a shop called the
silver platter
he was crooked the silversmiths was
selling cheap fakes oh well he's gone
now and so are most of his customers no
sense in stirring up trouble at this
point you write down the location of the
shop might come in handy alrighty then
alright well huh a spittoon at least it
looks like a spittoon but it's next to
the bed it might actually be a bedpan
here we go investigate it what really I
mean if it is just a spittoon that's bad
enough but it might be a bedpan and that
would be way worse investigated I feel
like maybe you are getting what I'm
saying we're talking about an object
that somebody probably uses when they
wake up in the middle of the night and
can't be bothered to walk to the
outhouse and the best you can hope for
is maybe they only use it to spend
nighttime tobacco juice into it in which
case it's only full of rancid congealing
tobacco spit I'm investigating are you
even listening to me or you just sort of
skimming past the texts bedpan look
[Laughter]
sharp I'm investigating it okay fine
have it your way
your own filthy disgusting way it turns
out to probably not be a bedpan but it
is definitely a spittoon and it is
definitely filled with rotting Brown
spit Brown in it what is wrong with you
bite me oh good god okay you plunge your
hand in up to the wrist it makes a gloop
sound and breaks the thin skin of
congealing toxins that was previously
keeping the dire smell in relative check
you are now joking miasma of oily bitter
chopstick you know that feeling when
you're about to buek how you get that
taste way back in the rear corners of
your mouth not metallic tang by the root
of your tongue like you're sucking out
an old corroded penny just tell me what
I found already
you filthy slime-covered old brooch are
you happy I bet you're gonna put it on
maybe I will
[Music]
[Laughter]
whose bridge would be much smaller if it
weren't for the big layer of tarnish and
tried to backhoe spit goes on your lapel
I don't know what my lapel oh is that
where the sheriff badge goes nasty ring
a revolting brooch oh [ __ ] what's my
luck I'm finding all these goddamn
spittoons by random it's destiny I tell
you alright let's get out of here
Templar we're gonna wander a bit welp we
want over oh go there now Stern's ranch
Hey Oh needles needles hello angry cows
have been here seeming do you guys get
much travel from the cows some not like
a ranches do mostly leaving us alone but
a running ends they happen so mean very
angry very fire full yeah no kidding
alright whatever
see what we got here woo alrighty then
now I need safecracking alright partner
looking here flat wall cow that's weird
alright food you got cats eye candy and
sugar guns weird cow shapes stand on the
wall it's probably something to do about
that later on man there's a lot of
secrets in this game it's great all
right got locking the lasso and a
depressed branch for candy boo what's
going on air so much burnt poor humans
I wonder we burn the bodies not cows
this is hobbies' now probably a neighbor
I guess okay
lockpick and Plus needle all right I got
stock certificate that's good I like me
some stocks still some beans in the pot
got blackened beans
[ __ ] ooh hello Mary Stern's diary talk
to ya a creepy burnt porcelain doll okay
hold the string you pull this string the
dolls eyes roll into the back of its
head its mouth begins to move hi I'm
grace what's your name
I'm mum Fleur I'm um Fleur you're nice
do you
to play with me yes let's play hooray
Mary used to play with me but we didn't
get to finish our Tea Party before she
went away will you help me finish it
Shirley hurray the game is almost over
Mary did such a good job dolls eyes roll
back forward go downstairs and get my
cup do you know the magic word to make
the mean cow let you into a secret room
Oh what is it the magic word is peanut
butter got it
peanut butter you shudder as you realize
that talking dolls haven't been invented
yet
spooky alrighty then well yeah that's
too bad for me I'm probably cursed for
all eternity but I guess I'm just gonna
be fine whisper peanut butter Oh at a
cow altar atop this sinister looking
altar sits a copper goblet filled with
what appears to be blood should probably
destroy that goblet I've had my run-in
with I don't know a lot about you goblet
but I believe is one up to people to
tell me whether or not that's good or
not to do that so if you guys know
whether or not that's good enough to do
that I'll leave it sit right where it
lie I don't want to be responsible for
anything bad between the smoke and the
noise you're guessing to the contents of
this outhouse are more dangerous than
the average Mary Stearns Gwendolyn
Stearns huh flowers smoking picking
smoking chrysanthemum
Lode father Jethro's bones were dug up
got a charred locket interesting man I
got a lot of yep charred locket
examining pick the lock
uh-huh picture of Mary Stearns that's
weird the back has written Mary Stearns
Thanksgiving where was that yeah the
diary the first page in the little
girl's handwriting doesn't the diary
Maris turns the AI and diary are crossed
out and IA are written above them the
dot hid the diary starts out as typical
kids fluff you flip ahead until you
noticed the writing getting shaken here
found in dolly under a cactus out back
and she told me her name was grace momma
and Popa don't believe that she talks
they say I got an imagination gray says
the cows are gonna get us but Papa says
we'll be ok cuz this weren't never a cow
range gray says he's wrong but Papa
won't believe me gray says she can keep
the cows away but I have to play tea
with her I don't like this kind of tea
party but grey says it's important to
keep the cows away mama said mama was
sad that they couldn't find Effie Papa
said she's been gone so long and they
think they should put a cross up but
mama won't let him because she thinks
that she'll come back Papa said she's
only 11 how far could she have gone and
mama started crying again don't want to
play tea party anymore but grey says I
have to Papa was out two days looking
for Joey but course he didn't find him
mama cries so much I tried to tell her
him and after you helped him keep the
cows away but she doesn't understand I
told grace I'm not playing tea party
again but she says I gotta and if I
don't cows will eat all three of us oh I
know what she's doing she said either I
get mama or Papa to play or else I got
to play by myself that's the last
century
I know what the cups for now I know what
the cups for hey oldest ringing mom
Fleur I've already played this yeah I
don't think I should get your cup
boy that's a bad idea I'm gonna still
leave that up to you guys cuz that seems
like a bad idea it seems like the worst
idea ever oh man but there's so many
different ways to go about things okay
but anyway I think I'm at the end of
this episode here thank you everybody so
much for watching now that I don't have
the hat I can actually play the game and
have fun with it Oh before I go let me
kill what's in this outhouse here and
see if there's something else here oh hi
boy these jerks are quick Gary no Wow
Gary just can't be hit parently it's
impossible oh I want to attack Gary
alright well let's give this gander see
if I'm still up to the challenge of
getting Fifi I've got a lot of muscle
and moxie BAM baby alright how about you
BAM
Gary Foom Oh Gary got your fool let's
see you find it quickly pistol aah
hooray another stinky tool to add to my
terribly stinky collection ads deal
stealth stench damage instead of that's
horrible apply five poison I'll take
that I'll take another disgusting thing
oh that's funny anyway that's all the
time I got for this episode I love this
game so much it's so funny so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you think down the comments
below and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]
you